d'accord, allons au travail
hey Ron quand tu flippes non oui
tu es
quelqu'un qui vient de me montrer ce que nous sommes
censés faire chaque fois que nous entrons
dans une nouvelle de ces émissions rapides et
furieuses c'est toujours que pouvons-nous faire de plus grand
mieux, je suis rapide, nous essayons toujours de
faire un petit effort supplémentaire et d'essayer de le
pousser un peu plus loin que vous ne le
feriez normalement juste au moment où vous ne pensiez pas
pouvoir mieux entrer, hein, nous y voilà, nous faisons
la première partie de  la séquence où nos
héros sautent tous d'un avion en
chute libre puis parachutent dans la
bouche
il y a trois caméras Flyers tous des
parachutes et des caméras de casque
nous sommes en chute libre à 130 cent 40
milles à l'heure et nous avons deux voitures donc
il y a cinq choses  voler autour et un
hélicoptère nous sommes dans cet hélicoptère ou
essayons de regarder les plans en regardant
les voitures qui sortent il y a un parachutiste
à votre gauche il y a un parachutiste à votre
droite 300 pieds vous devez vous déplacer en
arrière il y a tellement de choses à faire
nous avons fini  les laissant tomber à 12 000 pieds
et ils ont ouvert à environ 5 000 vous commencez à
jeter toutes ces voitures ensemble,
vous devez déterminer l'espacement de ces
choses qui tombent très vite
ces voitures ont leur propre esprit,
elles font tout ce qu'elles ressentent
iront très vite ils iront très
lentement ils pourraient aller à gauche puis ils
vont faire demi-tour et aller à droite ils
viendront vers vous ils reculeront
nous manœuvrons nos corps sous la
voiture autour du capot pour leur donner
ce plan qu'ils recherchent, nous
devons être très précis sur nos caps
et nos altitudes,
nous devons calculer un
point de largage spécifique afin que les véhicules ne heurtent pas les
gens au sol,
mes plongeurs dans l'hélicoptère et
tout le monde reçoit  des photos incroyables
tout le monde vous avez tous eu des trucs incroyables
c'était l'un des moments les plus excitants
que j'ai jamais eu dans ma vie ça
a parfaitement fonctionné